[Musique]
demain il faut de fresnes avant de nous
c'est un peu noël à cri mais de tout
éventuel vote partage
ils vont du caillebotis c'est quoi ce
bordel
à toi connard ça a failli tuer ma femme
tuée c'est parfait j'appelle à bas coûts
réponse ils ont craqué elle a craqué la
mise en plis ou quoi la caisse à toi
t'as paul m c'est à une tête de gort
envie te prend une branlée quoi
[Musique]
à l'habitat pour vous calmer aller qu'on
s'engueule attendant tu reçois
j'arrivais des sons comme un soir je
vais te répondre moi non loin d'un crime
et de quoi as tu en fais partie
courez voir et il ya le moindre truc qui
me sifflent
ok je ne peux pas te parler
je suis occupée j'ai travail autour du
costume presque à les ouvrir
amy tu vas beaucoup chien le chat le
chat
[Musique]
mc il a bousculé alors je suis là par
hasard couillon la teinte est rassuré
parce que sinon je te remets mexicaine
du coin pour qu'ils transforment en
attaque aussi